[Musique]
ce jeudi 22 décembre le président du
Département Cyril Melchior était en
visite de terrain au Maïdo en compagnie
du préfet Jérôme philippini et de
l'Office National des Forêts le projet
de recalification des belvédères et de
l'ambition pour l'aménagement global de
la destination mydo présenté par les
agents de la Direction du Tourisme et
des espaces naturels étaient au cœur de
cette réunion sur site alors nous avons
eu la présentation aujourd'hui de
plusieurs étapes de l'aménagement de
revalorisation du site du Maïdo une
première étape qui va se constituer de
la requalification des belvédères après
les incendies qui ont eu lieu à la fin
2020 cette opération première étape va
se dérouler courant 2023 donc avec tout
l'aménagement de la zone avec une
licence en tamarin et ferronnerie et
tout un sentier d'interprétation ensuite
on a une deuxième opération qui est une
ambition sur un plus long terme que l'on
a appelé destination et d'autres ou
simplement parce que c'est une
destination touristique emblématique
c'est la seconde la plus visitée de
l'île qui nous permettrait justement
d'offrir à la fois des services et en
même temps un message de sensibilisation
sur la qualité du cycle la qualité en
termes de biodiversité les risques
incendies etc donc il y aura une
première opération qu'on a appelé maison
du Maïdo qui comprendra à la fois des
boutiques un espace de sensibilisation
espace de repos pour les mafatés et un
planétarium voilà c'est une opération
qu'on espère dérouler en études à partir
de l'année prochaine avec une livraison
des premières opérations 2028 on espère
le département j'ai à peu près de 40 %
de la surface de la réunion à travers
les espaces forestiers nous le faisons
avec l'opérateur historique qui est
l'ONF et nous portons des projets des
projets structurants pour le territoire
et ici hôpitaux Maïdo nous voulons faire
en sorte que bien l'espace soit corrigé
qui soit amélioré de façon à permettre à
tous les visiteurs d'avoir le meilleur
accueil possible il y a déjà eu des
efforts de fait mais on va aller encore
plus loin il y aura quand même de gros
investissements qui seront réalisés nous
sommes en train de réunir les budgets
nous sommes en train de finaliser les
appels d'offres pour pouvoir lancer les
travaux d'ores et déjà je peux dire que
l'année prochaine en 2023 et bien le
mail doit commencer à changer la matinée
s'est ensuite poursuivie au camp
d'ennemont pour la visite d'une parcelle
d'exploitation de Tamarin des hauts
gérés par l'ONF l'occasion de faire un
point d'étape sur la régénération de ces
arbres endémiques suite à l'attaque de
psil est un insecte ravageur exotique
qui en fait bloque la photosynthèse de
l'arbre et le fait donc mourir donc là
nous avons un chantier d'exploitation
qui a été réalisé par les bûcherons de
l'ONF et qui a permis de classer le bois
en trois qualités la qualité le choix 1
qui a été en fait livré à siège-bourbon
dans le code de contrat pour
raisonnement le choix 2 qui sera destiné
à des mises en consultation et le choix
3 qui est destiné au charbonnier pour
pour faire du charbon de bois à l'issue
sur anti-exploitation va passer la
deuxième étape qui a la méthode de
régénération de ces Parlement de Tamarin
à partir d'une double technique on
appelle une réaction assistée par
rapport de vous de qui sous le en fait
la voûte c'est un Lumus qui sous les
peuplement de tamarins qui contient des
graines de Tamarin donc qui permettent
d'une rénovation naturelle et si ça si
ça fonctionne en parfaitement il y aura
en plus une plantation d'arbres la lutte
contre les espèces invasives est un axe
fort de la politique de préservation des
milieux naturels du département le
président Cyril Melchior a d'ailleurs
affiché son souhait de lancer un
programme régional ambitieux de lutte
contre les invasives dès 2023
[Musique]